[Music]
welcome thanks everyone for coming this
afternoon my name's Fraser McDonald I am
a product guy on an IOT cloud at Google
and I'm John hood I'm CTO at smart
parking a company that's using IOT core
so thank you all for joining us we want
to ask you a question just to get things
rolling here just to get a bit of a
sense of who's joining us this afternoon
for the next 45 50 minutes so just by
some hands how many in the crowd today
are working directly for a municipality
okay so we got some hands from people
that are working with cities themselves
how about people that are working for
vendors that serve municipalities okay
so a good number there as well how about
people who have lived in a city Oh what
do you know all right so we've got some
subject matter experts here that's great
and I say that kind of a half kiddingly
but one of the one of the points that
John and I want to talk about today is a
bit of an idea of who are we building
these smart cities for what is the the
reason for making him not just how you
make him so I think everyone in the
audience has got a bit of a voice in
that so thanks for joining us so let's
warm up with a bit of a teaser take a
look at this kind of echocardiogram
looking thing off to the side here and
see if you might recognize some patterns
in it does anyone have any ideas of what
we might be looking at yeah you have
some urban areas some parking they're
definitely urban areas you're right in
fact if we show the names here we're
looking at some familiar areas you got
the bay area off to the side New York
London Tokyo San Francisco so what we're
looking at here is movements of people
on their mobile devices every one of
these dots is somebody that has opted in
in Google Maps on their phone for
location tracking so you've taken that
data anonymized it collected it and
you're looking at the living breathing
city here this is a 24 hour cycle of
where people are going what they're up
to and this is enormous ly valuable data
it gives us a bit of a sense of context
for what we're talking about today that
there's an incredible amount of
information
it's available to us if we can make use
of it so this is for people's personal
uses on their phones and maps and seeing
where they been but imagine how useful
data like this could be to people who
are planning traffic patterns people who
are trying to plan pickup routes for
waste management somebody who's trying
to get a new freeway going somebody
who's trying to choose where the next
neighbourhood the businesses should grow
in we're seeing a growth in mobile
devices we're seeing a growth in IOT
devices and we're seeing a simultaneous
growth in the ability to process this
data on a massive scale so this is just
the beginning of smart cities we're
getting into a really exciting age for
it so question you might have expected
coming to a tech conference coming to a
Google conference that we're gonna talk
purely about technology and is this what
smart cities mean the technologies so
yes and oh yes in that these are
definitely ingredients of a smart city I
mean having access to Wi-Fi is what
gives us the ability to collect data
having RFID transit passes are fantastic
resources for municipal planners to know
when and where are people going so we
can make smarter routes having
self-driving cars are gonna be an
enormous overhaul of what it means to
live and be transported inside of our
cities but these are ingredients I mean
in the same way that any ingredients
alone don't make a cake this isn't the
smart city itself what John and I want
to talk about today is a bit of a shift
and we're wondering if you join us in
this shift from thinking about a couple
of the nouns a couple of technologies of
smart cities to a few adjectives that
might describe them so over the next
little bit we're gonna do a few things
one is I'm gonna share a few stories of
what we've learned at Google from some
projects that we've been involved in
that overlap with the smart city space
so a bit of stories that we've had some
learning from and a bit of what ifs and
then we're gonna hear from John and
John's gonna tell us well if that's the
what if this is what it actually looks
like John and his company are building
the kind of infrastructures for cities
around the world right now that let them
make good use of their data and we're
gonna wrap up with a Q&A so before we
dive into some of these stories that
we've learned from I should call out
that this session is one in which we
have Dory so you might have been in a
session this morning that has Dory as
well it's a Q&A tool that we've got at
Google
and we're rolling it out and trying it
at this conference so if you go into the
mobile app that you have for this
conference and you go to our session you
might notice that there's a QA portion
in it where throughout the car to see
something that looks interesting or a
question crosses your mind in the moment
you can write a Q&A question and the
rest of your fellow audience members can
then vote it up and at the end of the
session we'll mix a bit of microphone
questions and Dory questions from our
moderator who will read that I would so
if a question crosses your mind feel
free to hop onto your app and ask it as
we go okay so let's take a look at some
stories of what we've learned at Google
from some smart city adjacent and
overlapping projects what's the first
adjective that comes to mind the first
adjective of smart cities that at least
John and I when we were sat down and to
sitting down a chat about this thought I
was efficient and I think there's a
reason for that is because it comes up
the most regularly for smart cities take
a look at this this is the list of the
most common smart city projects that are
underway right now in the world and if
you're taking a look at it you'll
probably notice a bit of a pattern to it
as well you've got parking street
lighting wasting energy management and
then a whole bunch of transportation
logistics and optimization
these are efficiency problems and one
part of it might be yeah these are the
low-hanging fruit these are areas where
an IOT sensor or actuator can really
help and not be too complex of a rollout
but another big reason for this is these
are areas of high ROI each one of these
is making the city better able to spend
its money or better able to allocate its
resources and a really important
adjective of a smart city is one that is
not wasteful with its resources so what
does an efficient smart city look like
in the project that we've worked on some
of you might remember this demo from
next 2017 this is a bit of a what-if
this is something that we showed which
is taxi cabs driving around a city so
we've got some simulated fleets of taxis
across New York and these taxis are
kitted out with something that's a
little different and instead of having
just a display ad in the back that's
showing you a clip or an ad for
something
they're also location aware they know
where they're picking up where they're
headed what time of day it is and with
just a little bit of that information we
were able to personalize the ads to
whoever might be riding in the car with
an incredible amount of accuracy it's a
tiny bit of additional data but it
produces a huge oak
so this is an example for ads but
imagine this kind of intelligence if it
were applied to real-time traffic
control if your city or your building a
tool Forest City was able to equip the
city's traffic control measures to
respond to floats and parades to respond
to an event that spontaneously happens
to respond to live traffic conditions or
imagine if this kind of real-time data
and a little bit of location in time
awareness was able to affect waste
collection so that's exactly this next
example this is a company called
an AVO and their Google customer and
they're building something pretty cool
which is a waste management solution and
instead of being the traditional take on
waste management which is usually sort
of schedule oriented and you know you
know your time when you're gonna get a
pickup the truck comes by they pick up
your bin whether it's full or not and
they drive off I never decided that they
were going to add some sensors in a bit
of an intelligence to the process so
they're parking or rather they're a
waste management solution is aware of
how much trash is in the bin they sell
this to companies that need a more
efficient pickup schedule and all they
did was put a couple sensors in to know
when trash is getting full and slapped a
GPS on their trucks and out of a small
change like that their customers got
better service because they had reliable
pickup and didn't have to think about
scheduling so much is starting to think
about waste management as a service and
they themselves got better optimization
out of the route because they could tell
the drivers exactly where to go and
where they were needed so what's another
adjective that might give us a bit of a
place to start for smart cities
participatory so what would that mean
there are a couple of perspectives you
could take on this and one of them is
participation of the people that live in
the cities themselves so here's another
project that we had some overlap with at
Google some of you in the audience might
recognize where in the world we are
flying over right now this is Japan and
specifically this is an image that was
captured back in 2011 when in the
Fukushima area of Japan there were three
nuclear reactors that melted down and it
was a major public safety concern and
there was a pretty incredible response
in 2011 what we're looking at here is a
couple people in Japan that were
citizens put together Geiger counter
kits
they were makers and tinkerers and
shipped them out to people other
citizens around the country who got him
built him connected him up to the web on
a platform called patch Bay at the time
and overlaid it on top of Google's maps
and what you're seeing here is people
getting involved in producing and
engaging with the data of their own
cities to make them smarter
this was real-time intelligence on
should I be in my area am i safe now
this is an interesting impersonal one
for me because this platform patch Bay
went on to become the SciVal a IOT
enterprise platform that Google just
bought earlier this year and is getting
rolled in as part of the IOT core cloud
offering the next one here is sidewalk
labs you might have heard of this one as
a sister company of Google underneath
alphabet and sidewalk has a mandate to
not think about the city of next year or
three years from now they're thinking
about this what might cities look like
20 or 40 years from now so this is
another project we're involved with it
gives a bit of an idea of where why
might we be headed and sidewalks taken
on a really ambitious project it's
another one that's a little bit personal
to me as as a Toronto by myself growing
up not too far from that watercolor
toothpick on the left there this is a
micro city that sidewalks taking on in
Toronto they're gonna wire up absolutely
everything from the municipal
infrastructure to the transportation to
waste management to lighting and they're
gonna try to figure out what can we do
with the data so this story is just
beginning the sidewalk story is just
starting but what would it look like if
we wanted to try to affect some of these
changes and play with some of these
ideas right now we've done some of these
projects as Google what are some of the
tools as GCP that we're rolling out so
that we can help companies and
municipalities try some of these ideas
themselves so how might I tackle
efficiency in participatory city let's
take a look at Google Cloud IOT for a
minute so like much of GCP we're
building on the exact same tools and
stack that we build on for our own
products when you're looking at the
Google Maps infrastructure you're
looking at the same company that's
producing GCP tools for your company to
use and we took the same approach with
IOT this is an example of what an
infrastructure might look like for
powering a smart city project using a
couple of GCP building blocks so when I
left we've got our devices whatever they
might be whether those are occupancy
sensors they're smart energy meters they
are watching out for traffic patterns
these are the devices on the left that
have something to say or that might be
controlled like a stoplight and the tool
that we put together in the middle here
is cloud IOT core so this is a recent
product we've started rolling out
specifically for this use case there are
a lot of GCP ingestion tools for huge
amounts of data like pub/sub but the
unique thing about cloud IOT core is
that it's also meant for talking back
and it specifically meant for devices so
this is something that can run with any
hardware that your city is bringing
along any sensor or actuator over a
number of different protocols mqtt is a
lightweight protocol for devices that
are a bit more resource constrained HTTP
for something that has a bit more
compute power and overhead and doesn't
need quite that but this is a way for
you to give your devices a unique
identity and be able to talk back and
forth with them and tie them in to the
rest of the GCP ecosystem so you can
start making use of their data and we're
gonna talk a bit more about the rest of
this picture of what is making use of
their data look like just in a minute
what we're looking at here is a bit of
add these blocks together and we can
start playing with the ideas that we
were looking at in a couple slides
earlier all right let's take a look at a
couple more adjectives responsive so
responsive seems self-evident
you would want a smart city to be one
that can correct if something's going
wrong is something that's aware of
what's happening in its own grounds and
something that feels like it's not just
all operating on autopilot what's an
example of something responsive well
here's an example of something that
we've learned a bit from at Google and
this is a parking feature that we've
rolled out which is based entirely on
machine learning this isn't the same
level of granularity as what John's
about to talk to us about in a minute
this is just high-level this is just a
bit of information on where people are
sometimes and tried to make some
estimations on traffic patterns and
parking patterns based on that so if I'm
planning a trip to the mall or I'm going
to a city I've never been to I can get a
bit of an idea of it looks like I should
go at 10 a.m.
instead of 4:00 p.m. and this is an
example of something that doesn't just
show you where the parking lots are it's
responsive to when you might want to be
there what's another adjective
self-aware so this is one that I find
really interesting and really important
in the smart city space and it's quarter
rolling out any new programs as a
municipality or its core to being a
vendor to the cities because you can't
make good decisions unless you know
what's going on in your own grounds what
a self-aware look like for a city well a
lot of you I bet have used Street View
before I was just doing a trip last
weekend and had never been south on
Highway one before and was using Street
View to check out a couple of towns and
where's a nice spot for a hotel so
that's an example of how I can get a bit
of an awareness as a consumer but one
thing that we learned at Google from
Street View was the incredible richness
of image data and this picture that
we're looking at was useful to me is
somebody taking a ride but how could it
be useful to a city you might also be
familiar with google lens as a consumer
something else that makes a bit of
intelligence from images this is an
example of I take a picture of a flower
or I can have that flower identified for
me it was something that rolled out at a
recent IO and is chasing that exact same
problem of well we've got a lot of image
data in cities these days is there
anything we can do with that so this is
a consumer example what might that look
like in a smart city context how can I
take these adjectives responsive and
self-aware and look at some Google tools
that would let me chase that that would
let me learn from that so I'm pretty
excited to be able to chat about this
one today as it's a relatively new idea
that some of our teams have been playing
around with and it's a combination
between some of our learnings from
Street View and our machine learning and
image processing tools and the GCP tools
that are offered publicly so none of
this is you have to ask for special
permission this is all GCP tool
capabilities but it's an idea that we
are looking actively for early partners
on so if it looks like something that's
interesting to you reach out to me after
the talk Geno lens is the consumer
product it will take an image and tell
you a rough idea of what's in the image
what you might also know is that inside
GCP there are a couple image processing
tools that go
deeper than that the vision API is
effectively that for your apps if you're
building something that has a photo
capability you can send the image to the
cloud vision API and it will return with
a level of confidence what it thinks is
in that image and that's great for a lot
of you use cases if you want to be able
to tell yeah this is a car or this is a
park or this is a tree it's an
incredibly powerful thing to build in
with absolute simplicity to an app but
what if I wanted to go one level deeper
what if a city really wanted to get to
know what's going on on its grounds
without having to kit out an enormous
sensor network let's go one level deeper
to the next product called Auto ml and
this is where you can start training
your own image recognition models so
this starts to get really powerful as
cities start wanting to ask questions
about what's going on on our grounds now
our own Street View imagery isn't
publicly available and isn't available
to process for a number of privacy
reasons but images that a city is taking
itself are well within their right to
process so what might it look like to
take a look for are there trees close to
powerlines that might be a risk right
now are there potholes in the road that
we might need to be keeping track of
these two products are built for exactly
that cloud vision API gives you a good
idea of what's in a picture and is dead
simple they integrate to your
applications you pass it an image it
passes back what it thinks is in that
image if you want to go one level deeper
and you're working on an application for
a city that says we'd love to help you
answer a very specific problem then
cloud auto ml will let you very simply
with and without a data scientist on
your team create new models that will
allow you to identify what you're
looking for so imagine what this could
do for cities if you could get a better
idea of real estate value out of images
if you could take a look at where are we
at risk for a tree falling on a line
where are we looking promising for new
areas of growth based on businesses and
buildings that are booming in that area
an idea of could we look for indicators
of energy surge of production could we
look for measures quantitatively of
development of poverty of living
conditions in our cities these are tools
that are on GCP today
so we've talked to Cup a bit about a
couple of the projects that were working
on at Google and we've talked a bit
about what we learned from them and what
are some of the GCP tools that might
help you ask those same questions in
your cities let's go one level deeper
imagine if you were never stuck looking
for parking and to answer that question
please join me in welcoming Upjohn
[Applause]
thanks Fraser yeah we're living in a
changing world aren't we and parking is
one of the things that we live with
which really sucks and so I just want to
tell you a little bit about who we are
and what we've been doing for now 15
years we've had to build a lot of
Technology ourselves because there are
no standards but we're doing it in the
real world every day today so we're
based out of several locations around
the world Australia New Zealand and the
UK we actually dog food our own
technology in the UK and we run the
hundreds and hundreds of car parks
across the UK with our own technology
but in New Zealand in Australia and
other parts of the world we have a
number of very significant smart parking
systems in place tens of thousands of
sensors we build sensors that go in the
ground just like that yes just want an
example of one it's not much bigger than
a D size battery and it has to last for
up to 10 years in the ground so that's
sort of things that we do so we've had
to do Hardware we've had to do software
we have to do networking etc and it's
all powered today on Google cloud
platform so this is just a quick list of
some of the cities that today are using
the smart parking solution and we're
starting this is a still journey in in
progress you know a lot of the things
that we're doing are still just the very
basics of just show me where a car park
is you know tell the city or the
business how the parking is used you
know
it being used efficiently and
effectively and continuously or is it
underused or is it overused is the
pricing right are the types of rules
such as how much time you're allowed to
park in a certain parking spot actually
appropriate etc so these are just some
of the cities that we're running today
and the big question where we're
starting to pose is what about your city
so today we already you know as you can
appreciate we've had to build a
comprehensive range of solutions and
this diagram just illustrates some of
the types of functionality targets or
audiences that this technology delivers
to first of all the person in the car
driving we deliver a broad range of
applications which give guidance and
information about parking spaces as
using Google Maps using Street View is
all that sort of interactivity that
convenience that connection with you and
so that you understand what's actually
happening and where you're going and
then and then finally be able to
actually pay for that parking session
whether it be a pay for what you use so
you know a timer starts to just tick
away the time and when you've finished
your car parking session and you drive
away it closes that session and we do
that today or you know it can be fixed
you know prepaid you know you pay for 20
minutes or pay for 30 minutes or
whatever so that's one class of
application that we are delivering and
just last week we delivered two new
application two new versions of that
application to customers in other cities
the enforcement officer you know I know
you know this is probably the least
desirable aspect of parking but there
are people that need to actually go
along the streets and and effectively
and efficiently manage where the cars
that are just not playing by the rules
right and and and do the necessary thing
of putting a ticket on your window now
what we give is live real-time
information to those officers on the
street telling them exactly where the
car is
exactly how much they paid when did it
expire etc etc etc so and this is
real-time information a lot of what
Fraser was just talking about it's about
being alive the city is alive and and
these sort of things need to be
constantly moving talking about IOT one
of the things that we have found well is
a necessity of parking is that this is
actually legally enforceable IOT as you
well know as being drivers and and you
know you've ridden the cars and parked
on cars we all have right a car can
actually leave a parking space and
another one pull in right away right and
we're talking about wouldn't a second
assuming you're not speeding too fast
but it happens really really fast and if
we didn't detect when that new car comes
in we could give a parking ticket to
that second arrival we can't allow that
and this is actually the rigor and the
significance of the class of IOT that
parking is now also as I commented
before this is a battery operated thing
and it has to last for years but
meanwhile we're doing this real-time
communications we buried in the ground
and it's usually in concrete or timac
cement and so on it's very very nasty
for radio communications we've had to
develop that type of radio
communications and finally we put big
metal things overtop of it right which
also gets in the way of doing reliable
secure robust radio communications so
these are the sort of this is the class
the edge of IOT that parking is all
about in smart parking has solved and I
can tell you you know we've got a lot of
wounds on our backs a lot of a lot of
scars from learning this technology and
in fact as I commented you know
dogfooding our own technology has been a
really really good way to make sure that
we do the right thing what has actually
started to come back to us from our
customers you know from those cities
from those customers who are utilizing
our smart parking platform is once they
put those gateways those communication
Gateway's onto their lampposts right and
getting power and and network
connectivity to them either through 3G
4G or or some sort of other
communications mechanisms that gateway
becomes a very strategic element for
building out more sensing and more
capability into the smart city
infrastructure and and the solutions
that a city wants to actually deliver
and so what we've we've been actually
being told by our customers and we're
responding to is building an open
platform and open framework which
enables smart cities and so it's not
just about parking it's actually about
modern life in cities pretty much as
Fraser and I am talking about now and
where this is taking us is actually in
to building a broad range of solutions
that sit on top of the smart cloud
platform which is completely GCP it's
actually 100% pure service as well
there is no Linux operating system in it
there is no Windows operating system in
it it is completely built utilizing GCP
serverless computing components and this
is really exciting because I believe
this is actually the future for how we
build large-scale internet scale global
scale live network computing systems
which is essentially what I'm going to
talk about here now the first building
block that we utilized was the cloud
core IOT functionality that Google
provided and we did this we started
using it around about two years ago
prior to that we'd actually been
building our own our own IOT framework
for managing our devices but as we were
listening to our customers and seeing
the need for right before smart cities
we needed an open IOT framework and it
just did not make sense to reinvent that
wheel especially when you had solid
serverless technology that was also
going to be driven by the market that
was going to be open and flexible that
we didn't I just our team didn't need to
rebuild we didn't even need to support
it
you know we don't need to now maintain
that technology and we can trust that
GCP and Google are going to drive that
more and more into the the functionality
requirements of the market and we just
are able to benefit from it and as I
commented before this is actually giving
us city scale live responsiveness we are
doing today with those cities that I
listed before in the order of about a
million and a half to two million event
sensor event transactions per day what
you might not have noticed also on that
slide that previous one that diagram was
we also do cameras you know there's
especially in in the UK we do a lot of
number plate recognition and we're doing
about a million images per week and and
so that's the class of computing the
class of the capacity of data that we're
processing through this platform called
smart cloud the following three things
that I talk about here is one of the one
of the objectives of our smart cloud
platform was to actually eliminate the
need to have software developers
involved in everything that a customer
wants we wanted to enable the customer
to build their own dashboards their live
dashboards to display them anywhere that
they needed to without requiring us to
go and hack some code the same is true
for data analytics and data processing
and what we have actually done is we've
used bigquery and data studio which is a
fantastic tool you know isn't it my
analogy is you know Gmail to email is
data studio to Big Data it's actually
that is free like Gmail is is it's an
amazing tool and I'll show you in a
moment just from some displays of those
sort of reports that we're generating
directly from smart cloud which is using
bigquery underneath it the same is true
for business rules for parking there are
very complex processes for managing
business rules in a time of day when
parking can occur for certain types of
uses of that parking when is enforcement
being enabled and when is it not certain
car parking spaces may become non car
parking spaces that set for 30 to allow
traffic flow all those rules including
also other things such as has a payment
arrived
have they overstayed their welcome and
that parking space because they've gone
beyond the maximum period you're allowed
to park so all those business rules
which historically we wrote custom code
into the system and you know had some
sort of a UI that you type in some data
you know typically into a database now
what we have is an if this thin there
that rules engine which processes us
continuously and I mentioned our mobile
apps for guidance and payments and other
things
in fact the app area is just so
significant and you know we're all users
of apps what we also realized was you
just don't want to have yet another app
you know and it is you know there are a
number of surveys that have already
shown that you know after 90 days or so
of getting a smartphone you don't
typically don't load on the rap you know
getting that footprint onto your phone
is really really hard and so what we've
built is an app framework obviously we
have you know full functional apps and a
smart parking app on the App Store's
today is our app and and a variety of
cities a number of the cities that I
listed there have taken that out app and
we've we've actually branded it and
facilitated and with functions that this
is appropriate for them but more
interestingly is taking those components
such as the guidance component or the
payment component and embedding it in
your own app and so that's the framework
for mobile apps that we've also
developed and finally managed API API is
actually how you integrates how you
enable innovation with ourselves
internally how you work with partners
and and software vendors as well as
integration with city systems and so a
full suite of of managed api's which are
and that is using the apogee technology
from Google
cloud you know guess what so just want
to quickly now show you if we can switch
to the demo yay
I must admit we had a little bit of a
network issue as I sort of walked up but
here here's a live picture of one of the
cities it's actually Wellington City the
capital of New Zealand so one end of the
world and and what we've got here is I
can unzoom Ian into the city these are
the parking bays that I around the city
of Wellington and I can see that that's
been vacant for 38 minutes this is live
live data right from the city right and
this is just one aspect of visualization
and because it's built into dashboards I
can do such things that I push it into
full-screen mode and display you know
you can put it onto big screens
elsewhere every every one of these
dashboards is just a URL and one of the
powerful things is I can create my own
dashboards and there are some default
ones there's the data smart zone is what
we call our infrastructure area where we
can monitor and see see the
infrastructure and and what you saw
earlier on and phrases slide is that
that sort of map of the city's
activities going on well here where
we've got on one of the other what we
call tiles is actually the 24-hour cycle
of the heat map of the parking
utilisation on the city and this is just
another bit of insight that we're
providing cities if you notice just just
some of the things prove this is
real-time you can see the the numbers
changing there those are parking events
that are happening on the other side of
the world right now
here's another city this is Hamilton
City in New Zealand as well and I think
I've lost the other ones I was going to
also show a couple of cities like
Cardiff and so on so can we go back to
our slides so just going back to those
sort of smart city requirements one of
the things that we in smart parking and
in the smartpak a solution I have to
respond to and pretty much what Fraser
was talking about is just live streaming
this constant this instantaneous world
that we live in and this is a change for
how computing needs to be done it's no
longer store something to do a database
then retrieve it do some sort of
processing on it produce a report and
then store it back into a database etc
things have to be instantaneous and
responsive you know for example if you
were driving down the street and you're
using Google Maps and it took twenty
seconds to sort of give you the next
turn you'll probably be on the wrong
Street up a tree or something like that
so this is the new norm is live
streaming the efficiency and convenience
and I've been talking just indicated the
things like apps that we're delivering
the dashboards providing those
dashboards to any display whether it be
a display on on a street because it's a
URL anywhere there's a browser that can
be displayed and one one of the the
experiments that we were actually
working through is just using Android
Android things to display that in remote
places on to other displays and this is
really great for providing that
convenience of information where it's
pertinent and a dashboard can be just
for example how many bays are in this
area of a street or in this honest floor
of a parking building and so this is all
about connecting insights to you and the
UI mean here is there are many different
audiences you know it can be you the the
user of parking but it may also be the
city strategist who wants to have
understanding of the of what's actually
really going on either the uses and
mechanisms that are being operated for
the parking is it optimal for the city
you know as we all know it becomes very
very inconvenient and and challenging
when you're circling round and round
blocks just trying to find that Park
now using this real-time data accurate
data we can take you right to that Park
and when it changes we net we're letting
you know as well what we're doing is
we're starting to create the ability to
enable new outcomes and we've done that
both on the technology so rather than
using classical computing and I actually
class using standard traditional servers
and server os's as being classical we've
gone completely service completely what
I call cloud native for this platform
it's essentially the same way that Gmail
works the same way that Google search
works is how we've built
smart smart cloud our platform and it's
enabling ourselves and also our
customers to actually achieve new
outcomes and this is driving us to
become more responsive with our roadmap
you know a road map is no longer a
12-month road map it's actually dynamic
and changing because the way we're
implementing the functionality and the
way we're enabling our customers to also
have their roadmaps of functionality is
is in a much more agile in a much more
modular and freed democratized manner
democratizing over word used word I
think in this conference so here's just
a quick view of the architecture of
smart cloud and as you can see it's
heavily GCP and as I mentioned totally
service so I see core is where we ingest
and we send out messages from and we
also manage these tens and tens of
thousands of devices both the gateways
and the sensors that are actually in the
streets or in the parking buildings I
don't know if you've been to parking
buildings where you see the red green
lights over parking bays it's quite
common in some some parts the world
certainly it's very popular on in
Australasia and and it changes your
whole dynamic you drive into your
parking building and you literally will
just glance out of the periphery of your
vision too
seed a parking spot yet and yeah and
then we put signs throughout just saying
okay there are five up on level four and
there are twelve up on level five and so
on and and also just be able to glance
at other site so this sort of
information is all being managed by IIT
core both the the measurement and also
the control of those indicators for
example we're also managing the data in
a very dynamic ways I talked about using
bigquery as the fundamental core for big
data but simultaneously we're using
BigTable which is essentially the engine
underneath Google search to also manage
this parking events in real time and
then the API is I commented about four
dashboards for payments and and actually
any application so over to you now
hopefully that's given you a taste of
what we do the point is that what we're
doing is real-world IOT that is trying
to and is actually reinventing the
experience for cities already
[Music]